on reste dans la 11e circonscription des
yvelines jusqu'au 12 juin date du
premier tour des élections législatives
tv 78,2 vous aide à y voir plus clair
sur les enjeux dans chacune des 12
circonscription des yvelines pour parler
de la 11e circonscription nicolas
d'ombré est avec moi en plateau bonsoir
bonsoir il y aurait de la rédaction de
tv 78 l'entendait dans le sujet
précédent sur nuxe nicolas annuler
justement pour l emporter dans cette
circonscription en fait le candidat dit
ça parce que si on regarde les résultats
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de cette année est bien
jean-luc mélenchon arrive en tête dans
la 11e circonscription des yvelines avec
33% des voix suivi des manuels macron
avec plus de 28% des suffrages et si on
vers plus près dans certaines communes
de la circonscription attrape le
candidat de la france insoumise dépasse
les 60% à la verrière les 50% et comme
vous l'avez vu dans le sujet la
candidature de la nuque et porté par
williams martinez et donc comme il le
dit ce qui sera déterminant c'est la
participation trappe la verrière voici
deux des communes de cette 11e
circonscription mais il y en ad'autres
intense elles sont viables à verrières
on retrouve les communes d'elancourt de
saint cyr l'école de bois d'arcy de
fontenay-le-fleury et du
mesnil-saint-denis alors un peu
d'histoire ce territoire a connu
différentes bascule de la droite à la
gauche avec fit plusieurs figures le
politique locale élue à l'assemblée
nationale qui sont justement ces figures
politiques locales alors c'est notamment
le cas de l'ancien maire de trappes
socialiste guy malandain députés entre
1981 et 1993 en 1993 la circonscription
bascule à droite avec le maire
d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
jusqu'en 1997 puis vous savez il ya un
épisode avec la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale décidée par le
président de la république jacques
chirac eh bien c'est la socialiste
catherine tasca qui remporte le scrutin
un siège qu'elle cédera de nouveau en
2002 à jean michel fourgous pendant dix
ans la droite conservera ce territoire
puis en 2012 suite à l'élection de
françois hollande la circonscription re
bascule à gauche avec benoît hamon
jusqu'en 2017 après la victoire
d'emmanuel maquereau en 2017
la vague en marche passe aussi par la
11e circonscription des yvelines c'est
nadia candidates issues de la société
civile qui l'emportent nommé ministre en
2020 elle est contrainte de démissionner
de son siège à l'assemblée nationale une
élection législative partielle et donc
organisé en septembre 2020 et là c'est
le candidat les républicains philippe
benassaya qui l'emportent devant la
candidate de la gauche sandrine grand
gang avec 57% des voix alors depuis
l'ancien maire de bois d'arcy à la
sièges à l'assemblée nationale il
apporter notamment plusieurs
propositions sur les questions de la
sécurité et pour ces élections
législatives à venir il sera candidat
pour l'union de la droite et du centre
dans une 11e circonscription l'a compris
eu différents basculement de droite à
gauche de gauche à droite là philippe
benassaya le député de la droite qui est
sortant sera candidat nouveau qu'y
aura-t-il face à lui alors pour la
majorité présidentielle
aurélie pierre senza défendra le projet
d' emmanuel macron et du gouvernement
des lettres d'elisabeth porn autres
candidatures à gauche en marche en marge
pardon de la nile tv patrick planque
défendra les positions de lutte ouvrière
dans le camp des souverainistes et des
nationalistes le rassemblement national
sera représentée par sophie chabanais
alexandre michel arnaud portera les
couleurs de reconquête et olivier
galland ce sera le parti de nicolas
dupont aignan debout la france puis
plusieurs mouvements politiques seront
représentés pour le scrutin législatif
dans la 11e circonscription c'est le cas
notamment de l'union des démocrates
musulmans avec raouf maïza le party
animal il sera porté par christophe
aubin jean-luc tramoni portera l'union
des centristes et des écologistes et
enfin aymeric de la fosse le parti
pirate merci nicolas pour toutes ces
précisions sur la 11e circonscription
des yvelines où on continue dans ses
éditions du journal également dans
l'émission 7 8 week-end de vendredi nos
tour d'horizon sur ces circonscriptions
à venir demain dans le journal un focus
sur la 10e circonscription des yvelines
c'est cette circonscription du sud
divine et je vous rappelle les dates de
ces élections législatives le 12 juin
pour le premier tour et le 19 juin pour
le deuxième tour